some years ago the grand challenge in
computer science or one of them was to
build a machine that could beat a chess
grandmaster some may remember with us
and we built machines that got better
and better at it but finally built a
machine back in the 90s called deep blue
and it played against Garry Kasparov and
it beat Garry Kasparov and I think he's
still quite upset about why did we build
that machine well it really wasn't to
play chess it was to take a real
challenge chess and it would force
advances in computer science and it
worked quite well
well that was chess and that was the
nature of the Grand Challenge back then
but today this explosion of data most of
it unstructured data natural language
tweets blog posts medical images things
like that very difficult for traditional
computers to understand it could store
it it could process this data but it
doesn't know what the data really tells
you because it's unstructured the
research team some years ago said what's
a way for us to create a system that is
ideal for the coming world of
unstructured big data natural language
making sense of a mountain of data what
what could we do to force ourselves to
to solve those problems and they hit
upon the game show Jeopardy now I got to
tell you that when they came by to see
me
IBM corporate headquarters I don't know
six years ago seven years ago maybe
longer and they said we've identified
the next big challenge similar to the
chess machine
that'd be Kasparov I was thinking you
know wow they're gonna go after some
really sophisticated high-minded you
know game theory thing and they came in
and said it's going to be jeopardy now I
wasn't really a jeopardy watch her back
then I'm there with the game I said you
mean the TV quiz show and they said yes
and I said well that's that's seen
to be they remind me of this now it
doesn't seem to be very you know
sophisticated or challenging and they
went on to explain to me and I'm of
course had to acknowledge many times to
them since then it's really hard it's
really hard to win on Jeopardy and it's
hard for a human and it's almost
impossible for a machine because if you
play jeopardy or if you're just kind of
familiar with it you have to understand
puns and allegories popular culture
rinds
allusions double entendre these are
things that computers are baffled by the
other than some humans so they went
after this and they struck a
collaboration with producers of jeopardy
and they built the system called Watson
and it played the two greatest human
champions Ken Jennings and Brad Rutter
some years ago I was there watching it
do its thing live and in it won and the
remarkable thing about Watson that's the
name of the system we believe it's the
first cognitive computer and what is
that it is a system that isn't
programmed it is a system that learns it
is a system that improves itself by
ingesting all the data it can and by
being trained by humans and this is a
profound shift in computation because
whether it's a powerful supercomputer or
it's your iPad all of those systems are
programmed to do what they do your iPad
can only do what it what a software
engineer designed it to do that is not
the case with Watson Watson improves
itself through learning and it is
therefore incredibly important in this
world of big data most of it
unstructured we will need systems like
Watson to make sense
of all the data that's being produced
watson triggers some very strong
emotions and people when they learn
about it or see it or interact with it
it talks it answers questions with great
confidence if it doesn't know the answer
the question it sometimes ask you
another question to help it reason on
the question it generates hypotheses and
tells you its level of confidence in its
recommendations and so we as humans we
use all kinds of words that we're
familiar with to try to understand what
this thing is doing we say is it
thinking
is it sentient is does it create some
people get very excited and optimistic
because Watson seems to be the answer to
a lot of problems it never forgets a
doctor can't read every piece of medical
literature that's created everyday
Watson can by the way Watson's at work
at Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer
Research at MD Anderson Cancer Research
at the Cleveland Clinic and a 12-point
learning medicine it will never replace
the the human expert the doctor for
example but it can do things that no
single human can do other people take
that same reality or potential and that
causes some level of anxiety I think
it's appropriate to always be weighing
and discussing the advantages and
potential disadvantages of technology
and I'm very proud of the fact that IBM
does this I mean we we do feel
responsible to build capabilities and
innovations that are used properly and
Watson I think is one of those so does
Watson think does Watson have a
consciousness Watson does not have a
consciousness or is not conscious or
sentient the way that you and I are but
does Watson learn does it take in
information and is better more powerful
more valuable because of
having taken in that information it does
that does it learn because we humans can
tell it that is the right answer that
answer is not quite correct and if you
adjust certain things in your logic you
will never forget that that answer was
not quite correct yes Watson can do that
so in that regard it does mimic certain
aspects of cognition of the human being
it's not correct to say therefore it
does all the things or ever will do all
the things that you and I do